bonjour je m'appelle abdelazaka j'ai 21
ans j'habite au port je suis à la
recherche d'un contrat apprentissage
dans la coiffure dans la zone nord ouest
je suis en train de passer mon permis
j'ai un cap dans la série graphie
j'ai passé mon CAP au CFA de
saint-gilles-les-haut j'ai fait
plusieurs stages dans la coiffure
dans plusieurs salons de l'Ouest je vais
de la coiffure afro chez boire le
week-end je maîtrise shampoing le
brushing
les coupes
lissage comme j'ai déjà de l'expérience
dans la coiffure afro j'aimerais me
développer maintenant dans la coiffure
traditionnelle j'aime la musique j'aime
lire la randonnée les sports de combat
j'aime prendre des initiatives je suis
souriante autonome et j'apprends vite je
suis vraiment passionnée par la coiffure
j'aimerais vraiment me professionnaliser
dans ce domaine
appelez moi